مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
عراقي برئاسه مستشار الامن القوميه يصل
الى السليمانيه لبحث حادثه الهجوم على
المطر
سلطات شبه جزيره القرم تعلن اسقاط صاروخ
اوكراني وتؤكد عدم تسجيل اي اضرار نتيجه
الحادثه
امين عام منظمه التعاون الاسلامي يحذر من
اي محاوله لتغيير وضع المقدسات في القدس
وفي الرابعه ايضا
الجريده الرسميه السعوديه تنشر تعديلات
نظام حمايه البيانات الشخصيه الوصول
والاتلاف ضمن ابرزها
والارصاد السعوديه تتوقع استمراره طول
الامطار على مختلف المناطق حتى الخميس
القادم
وصل الى السليمانيه وفدون عراقي برئاسه
مستشار الامن القومي قاسم الاعرجي وذلك
لبحث ملابسات حادثه الهجوم على المطار
وقبل ذلك طالبت الرئاسه العراقيه تركيا
بتقديم اعتذار رسمي عن شن ضربات على مطار
السليمانيه واكدت في بيان لها عدم وجود
مبرر قانوني يخول للقوات التركيه لاستمرار
في نهج ترويع المدنيين بذريعه وجود قوات
مناوئه لها على الاراضي العراقيه ودعت
الرئاسه العراقيه تركيا الى وقف
الاعتداءات التي وصفتها بالسافره والذهاب
الى حوار مهدده باتخاذ موقف حازم اذا
تكررت ومن جههها دانت رئاسه اقليم كردستان
العراق الهجوم على مطار السليمانيه الدولي
واعربت ان قلقها تجاه ردود الفعل التي تلت
الحادثه بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين الحزبين
الحاكمين اشارت الى عدم السماح بتعريض امن
اهالي السليمانيه للخطر لاي سبب من
الاسباب
الجانبيه انا قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مظلوم عبدي محاوله الاستهداف التي نجى
منها ويرجح انها تركيا على مطار
السليمانيه وقال عبدي في بيانه ان هذه
الانتهاكات المستمره في سوريا والعراق لها
ابعاد خطيره على المنطقه مضيفا بان
علاقاتهم المبدئيه مع الحلفاء في
السليمانيه ستستمر وسيقفان في صف واحد ضد
هذه الانتهاك
وكانت مديريه امن السليمانيه فكردستان
العراق اعلنت ليله البارحه عن وقوع انفجار
بالقرب من سور المطار ولم ينتج عنه اصابات
وحسب مراسل العربيه تواجد قائد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي اثناء الانفجار
وفي الاثنان صرح مصدر امني لقناه العربيه
ان الانفجار في محيط مطار السليمانيه ناجم
عن هجوم بمسيرات تركيه قالت مصادر العربيه
ان تركيا لم تقصف طائره قائد قسد في
السليمانيه لوجود اجانب على متنها
واستخدمت تركيا القصف للتحذير
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني
احمد مرحبا بك ما الملابسات وما التطورات
حتى الان في ردود الفعل وخاصه في موقف
الحزبين الحاكمين في كردستان
خالد ما يزال المشهد طبعا ضباب الى حد ما
في موضوع الخلافات او اعاده المياه الى
مجاريها في موضوع الخلافات ما بين حزبي
السلطه باقليم كردستان العراق لما تزال
السليمانيه تسوق اتهامات لاربيل وما تزال
اربيل تتحفظ
وطبعا على كثير من الاتهامات
بالتالي فان العلاقه او الاتهامات زادت
طبعا امس بعد بيانات من بعد مرشقات
ببيانات ما بين
الناطق باسم الحكومه حكومه اقليم كردستان
جوت عادل
والنائب رئيس الوزراء الذي قبض طالباني
الذي هو شقيق بابل طالباني الزعيم الحزب
وايضا هو نائب رئيس وزراء وقد علق
مجتماعاته من قبل عده اشهر اي معلقه
اجتماعاته وغير فعاله في مشاركاتها
بالحكومه
وبالتالي بيانات متكرره وبيانات في
بينهم بالاضافه الى بيانات اخرى وطبعا
يحاول حزب الديمقراطي على ما يبدو التهدئه
وعدم التصعيد وبالتالي يحمل كان حمل جهات
سياسيه في السليمانيه بانهم من استدرجوا
وبتصرفاتهم بحسب قولهم استدرجوا هذا القصف
على مطار السليمانيه وكان بيان غاضب من
اربيل على على هذا رده فعل كانت غاضبه
وحملت سليمان لكن بالمقابل ان ان لم ان
هناك تحركات من بغداد
بوصول قاسم الاعرجي على راس وافد امني
رفيع الى مطار السليمانيه وقد التقى
مسؤولين هناك مدير المطار وما الى ذلك من
شخصيات امنيه للوقوف على ملابسات الحارث
لعله ايلارج يرفع تقريرا الى رئيس الحكومه
محمد شيعه السوداني
لمعرفه او الاتخاذ اجراء
اجراء عراقي نقول او اجراء رسمي من حكومه
العراقيه ببغداد لكن لا تسريبات عن اي
موقف عراقي يعني او اجراءات يمكن ان
تتخذها الرئاسه والحكومه العراقيه حتى لا
نحمل
طبعا الغريب في الموضوع انك كنا قد نتابع
في بعض المرات ان الخارجيه وما الى ذلك من
قنوات
عراقيه هي من
تطاطح او تستنكر او او تستدعس السفير
التركي ببغداد الا ان هناك غموض بالموضوع
يبدو ان سكوت او صمت تركيا هو من يساعد
حتى يكون هناك ادله على ان تركيا التي
قامت بهذا الهجوم على مطار سليمانيه قول
ان ايران
مستبعده من هذا السيناريو ان تكون ايران
هي
قامت بالهجوم قول الهدف كون الهدف هدف
تركي وليس ايراني بمعنى انه مقرب من ايران
وليس من تركيا
ننتظر بغداد وننتظر اربيل حتى يكون هناك
لكن رئيس الاقليم كردستان كان له الموقف
الابرز في تهدئه وطلب ضبط وطلب طلبي بضبط
النفس لكافه الاطراف الكردستانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك من اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد
الحمداني
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلينك ان
تكون هناك فرصه لاجراء محادثات من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار بين روسيا واوكرانيا وذلك
خلال مقابله مع مجموعه فونكا الاعلاميه في
المانيا في هذا السياق قال بلينك فكره
وقفي اطلاق النار مهما كانت مغريه فهي لا
تعني اطفاء الشرعيه الفعليه على استيلاء
روسيا على اراضي كبيره من اوكرانيا ولذلك
سيمثل سلاما عادلا او ان ذلك لن يمثل هذا
الوسم معربا عن قلقه من استغلال روسيا لا
يهنه لاعاده تجميع قواته واتخاذ اجراءات
هجوميه
على الصعيد الميداني اعلنت قوتنر العسكريه
الخاصه عن خوض معارك طاحنه بالقرب من محطه
السكك الحديديه في باخموت وافادت فاجنر
بتصاعد القتال مع تسلم القوات الاوكرانيه
عددا ضخما من معدات الناتو العسكريه
مركبات مدرعه بالاضافه الى دبابات
اليوبارد وشكل الجيش الاوكراني قوات
الاحتياط المؤلفه من نحو 200 الف شخص
كما اعلنت سلطات شبه جزيره القرمن انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت صاروخا اوكرانيا كان
يحلق فوق منطقه فيودوسيا في شرق القرن
ذكرت في بيان لها انها فعلت حاله الانذار
الجوي بعد اسقاط الصاروخ مشيره الى عدم
تسجيل اي اضرار
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك ما هي
اخر التطورات الميدانيه خصوصا في باخمت
بعد الانباء عن المعارك الطاحنه في محطه
السكك الحديديه
نعم خالد لكن قبل الدخول في
التطورات في باخمه لا بد من الاشاره الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه استانفت قصفها
لمدينه دانيت خلال اليومين الماضيين كانت
هناك عمليات عسكريه او ضربات
بصواريخايمرز الامريكيه كما انها استخدمت
صواريخ تشيكيه الصنع من طراز فامبير يعني
صواريخ جراد بولنديه الصنع سقطت في مناطق
مختلفه خلف القصف عشره
ضحايا واعداد من الاصابات وتزامن هذا
القصف مع تصريحات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين باهميه ابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه عن
مناطق المدنيين في دانيت وخاصه حديث عن ان
مهمه جيش الروسي هي ايقاف الحرب في او
ايقاف اطلاق النار في دمباس
المعارك طبعا مستمره على جميع المحاور في
مدن
واهمها مدينه باخمت
تقدمت القوات
الروسيه وقوات فاجنر تحديدا في عمق
المدينه بعد سيطرتها على المباني الاداريه
في قلب المدينه
وتخوض معارك شرسه بالفعل في مناطق السكك
الحديديه كما ان هناك مقاومه شرسه من
الاجانب الاوكراني في المحور الشمالي حول
بلده
اريخاباسيلوكا
ماذا لا تقاوم القوات الاوكرانيه في
المحور الشمالي والغربي وتمنع تقدم قوات
فارغنر كما ان الامدادات ما زالت تصل عن
طريق مدينه شاسوفيار التي عجزت عن
اقتحامها حتى الان قوات فاجنر هناك بلده
عصيت على القوات الخاصه الروسيه وهي بلده
بلداسكا في المحور الغربي لو صناعه القوات
الروسيه او قوات فاجنر الخاصه من اقتحام
المدينه والسيطره عليها لكانت قد اكملت
الطوق لكن الامدادات ما زالت تصل بسبب
صمود القوات الاوكرانيه في ذلك المحور
الاله العسكريه الثقيله تعمل في الجانبين
الجنوبي والشرق حيث القصف العنيف من قبل
من المدافع ومن راجمات الصواريخ كما ان
المقاتلات الروسيه ما زالت تحلق في هذان
الجانبين بالفعل هناك اكثر من خمسه خمسه
عشر الف مقاتل اوكرانيا حسب الاحصاءات
داخل مدينه باقمت كما ان هناك اعداد كبيره
مدينه باخمت خالد هي رمزيه للطرفين الطرف
الروسي والطرف الاوكراني حوالي ثمانيه
اشهر ولم يستطع الجيش الروسي او قوات
فاجنر السيطره عليها والطرفين معنيين اما
اذا كان الروسي اذا سيطر عليها فهذا يعني
انه سيتقدم الى المدن الكبرى خلفها واذا
صمد الجيش الاوكراني فهذا يعني انه قادر
على الصمود في هذه الحرب بشكل عام هناك
محاور كثيره افديفيكا ومارينكا وايضا
اجلادار معارك داريه في كل هذه المناطق لا
تتوقف المعارك ولا تقدم على الارض فعلي
يعني
يسجل للجيش الروسي هناك محاولات للاقتحام
لكن ليس هناك اي تقدم يذكر شكرا جزيلا لك
من دانيت مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
في تطور جديد ضمن قضيه الملفات السريه
المسربه كشفت صحيفه
عن ظهور مجموعه ثانيه من الوثائق تحتوي
على اسرار عسكريه امريكيه مشان اوكرانيا
والصين والشرق الاوسط
نزيف الوثائق المسربه مستمر داخل
البينتاجون واشنطن تعيش حاله استثمار قصوى
لضبط المتلبسين في القضيه دفعه جديده من
الوثائق المسربه من وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه تنتشر كالنار في الهشيم على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتهز عرش كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين الامريكيين صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كشفت عن تسريب ما يعادل 100
وثيقه سريه اضافيه تتعلق بالامن القومي
للولايات المتحده الوثائق الخاصه بالجيش
الاوكراني شملت صورا فوتوغرافيه لمخططات
تسليم الاسلحه كما شملت جزءا من الخطط
العسكريه المحتمله لاعتمادها في الهجوم
الاوكراني المرتقب ضد القوات الروسيه
التسريبات هذه المره لم تتوقف عند حدود
الحرب الاوكرانيه كما هو الحال في الدفعه
الاولى بل شملت ملفات اخرى تتعلق بقضايا
الشرق الاوسط والملف الصيني والمسرح
العسكري لمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
وملفات الارهاب
دفعه ثانيه اذا خلفت عاصفه من التهم
المتبادله حول المسؤول عن تسريب هذه
الوثائق من خلف ابواب البنتاجون المصاده
باحكام الاكثر من ذلك هو ان المسؤوليه قد
تتحملها وكالات مخابرات اخرى غير
الامريكيه كما هو الحال بالنسبه للمخابرات
الاستراليه
ونيوزيلنديه والكنديه والبريطانيه ايضا
التي تتعاون وتنقل المعلومات فيما بينها
لكن الخبر قد ياخذ ابعاد اخرى غير
المتداوله بشكل رسمي على وسائل الاعلام
فالتدفق المستمر للوثائق المسربات طرح
علامات استفهام حقيقيه حول صحه المعلومات
فقد يكون الامر متعلقا بحرب معلومات بين
روسيا والمعسكر الغربي طرح لم تستبعده
الكثير من الاطراف داخل موسكو التي وصفت
هذه التسريبات بعمل استخباراتي غربي من
اجل تضليل تقر صحيفه نيويورك دائما نقلا
عن مسؤولين الروس ووسط فوضى المعلومات هذه
يبدو ان الحروب الموازيه لحرب المدافع
ستكون اكثر حسما في هذا الصراع وسام
الذهبي العربيه
منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه حسين ابراهيم طه
بيانا حضر فيه من اي محاوله لتغيير الوضع
التاريخي والقانوني للمقدسات في القدس بعد
اقتحام الاقصى وحمل اسرائيل المسؤوليه
الكامله عن تداعيات الانتهاكات التي تؤدي
للتغذيه العنف وزعزعه امن واستقرار
المنطقه وشدد طه على ان السياسات
الاسرائيليه ليس لها اثر قانون قانوني
وتعد لاغيه وباطله بموجب القانون الدولي
وقرارات الامم المتحده
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
الداخليه السعوديه تضبط نحو 17 الف مخالف
للنظام الاقامه وامن الحدود خلال اسبوع
اهلا بكم من جديد نشرت جريده ام القرى
الرسميه في السعوديه تفاصيل تعديلات نظام
حمايه البيانات الشخصيه التي اقره مجلس
الوزراء في جلسته الاخيره شملتها التفاصيل
التي اعلنت عنها الصحيفه 27 تعديلا من
بينها
الائتلاف وحق الوصول الى البيانات كما
شملت تعديلا على اليه جمع البيانات
الشخصيه وسياسات الخصوصيه
الرياض ينضم الينا المحامي المستشار
القانوني احمد المحيميد سيد احمد حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابع صحح فقط الحمايه
البيانات ومن بين ايضا المواد الاتلاف
وليس الائتلاف اختلاف هذه مصطلح سياسي
يعني خلينا اسالك اول شيء عن هذا النظام
وهذه التعديلات لماذا تمت وما هي اهم
الاضافات التي جاءت في هذا النظام شكرا
شكرا لك تحت الفرصه والشهر المبارك لك
ولجميع المشاهدين ومشاهدات الكرام طبعا
نعلم ان النظام اصلا هو نظام حديث جديد
هذا النظام حمايه البيانات الشخصيه يعبر
عن اهتمام حكومه مولاي خالد محمد الشريفين
في المواطن والمقيم في الاعراض السعوديه
بحفظ حقوقهم سواء كان واحيانا او اموات
وابرز هذه الحقوق اللي هي حمايه البيانات
الشخصيه سواء كانت بيانات حساسه او بيانات
عامه او شخصيه بحته طبعا التعديلات اللي
وردت رغم احداثه النظام نظرا لاهميه هذا
الموضوع ونظرا لتعدد الانظمه المرتبطه
بهذا النظام متعدد الجهات المناط فيها
تطبيق مثل هذا النظام فبالاضافه الى
الهيئه الوطنيه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي عندنا الامن السيبراني عندنا
البنك المركزي عندنا القطاعات الامنيه
عندنا القطاعات المتعلقه
بحقوق وحمايه حقوق الانسان فكل هذه الجهات
يجب ان يكون بينها تنسيق وتكامل لمعرفه كل
قطاع وماذا عليه ان يكون به بخصوص حفظ
البيانات وزي ما تفضلت
يكون هنالك حوكمه لهذه البيانات حفظ لها
احترامها تفعيل الخصوصيه والسريه عقوبات
مشدده لمن يدلي باي بيانات خاصه البيانات
الحساسه لذلك كان هذا هذه التعديلات في
هذا الوقت
الى اي مدى استطاع هذه التعديلات تتجاوز
ربما الثغرات اللي كانت موجوده في النظام
السابق اتذكر كان هناك تحليل ربما تطرق
الى هذه المساله الان بعد التعديلات
الجديده هذه اعتقد انه هذا النظام تغلب
وتفوق على المعايير الموضوعه على المستوى
الدولي لحفظ البيانات الشخصيه انا اعتبر
النظام السعودي هذا نظام مثالي جدا من حيث
قوته من حيث صرامته من حيث مدى تطبيقه من
حيث الحفاظ على الخصوصيه من حيث ايضا
تشديد العقوبه في افشاء هذه البيانات هذه
النظام اعتقد انه تجاوز اي ثغرات لو كانت
موجوده انما هي تعديلات تطويريه وتحديثيه
لكي يتواكب مع رؤيه 2030 ويتواكب زي ما
تفضل مع الانظمه المعدنيه
او المواد اللي جاءت متواكبه او ملتزمه
ربما او متماهيه مع المعايير الدوليه اول
على الخصوصيه والسريه التامه سواء كانوا
احيانا او اموات يعني الانظمه عاده تحفظ
حق الشخص وهو حي الان النظام حفظ حقوق
الشخص وبيانات الشخصيه حتى بعد وفاته
اثنين ضمن انه في سريه تامه ولا يكون في
الافشاء لاي معلومه شخصيه خاصه المعلومات
الحساسه الا اذا تطلب دفع بلاء او دفع مرض
مثلا او انتشار عدوى او كان في هناك حكم
قضائي او كان هناك حاله امنيه تستدعي مثل
هذا الابصار فالتشديد النظام على مثل هذه
الامور لحفظ
بيانات الشخص انا اعتقد انه تميز النظام
السعودي شكرا جزيلا لك المحامي والمستشار
القانوني احمد المحامي شكرا لك
اطلقت امانته منطقه المدينه المنوره اعمال
المختبر المتنقل الخاص بفحص جوده وسلامه
الاغذيه والمياه للتاكد من خلوها من
البكتيريا المسببه للامراض
ومطابقتها للمواصفات بهدف ضمان سلامه
وجوده الغذاء المقدم لاهالي وزوار المدينه
المنوره طوال شهر رمضان يضم المختبر
المتنقل اجهزه حديثه لفحص المواد الغذائيه
في وقت قياسي
فعلت اداره خدمه الزائر الصغير برئاسه
العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام برنامج
الاساور لتفادي فقدان الاطفال في الحرم
المكي وسط الاعداد المليونيه التي يشهدها
المسجد في شهر رمضان وتحويل اساور وسيله
التواصل مع ذويهم اضافه الى برامج توعويه
وتثقيفيه للاطفال
[موسيقى]
اصطحاب الاطفال الى المسجد الحرام غايه
ورغبه عند الكثير من العائلات الا انها
محاطه بهاجس فقدانهم في ظل الاعداد
المليونيه التي تتوافد بشكل يومي لاداء
العمره او الصلاه في شهر رمضان اداره خدمه
الزائر الصغير تستقبل طلاب المدارس في
المسجد الحرام
وتوعيتهم على ما تقدمه الرئاسه من خدمات
جليله مبادره اسواره معصم اليد واطلقنا
عليها طفلك معنا بامان تحتوي على بيانات
ذوي الطفل لا سمح الله في ضياعهم يتم
التواصل معهم وتوصيله في اقرب وقت ممكن
لتفادي الكثير من حالات فقد الاطفال في
المسجد عملت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين على توزيع
اساورات توضع على مهسم الطفل وتحمل
معلومات التواصل مع ذوي فضلا عن برامج
توعويه وتثقيفيه تقدمها
في رحله امنه للمعتمرين واطفالهم لو حتى ط
فل بيبداوا يتواصلوا معه وبيصل الى ابنه
وده شيء ممتاز جدا وشيء جميل جدا وربنا
يوفقكم وربنا يوفق القائمين على العمل
بصراحه كثير مبادره كويسه يعني
بتقدر ما بتخليك تخاف على اولادك وخلاص
روحوا اسرحوا وين وين ما تبون يعني خدمات
مكثفه تراعي كل الفئات والاعمار في المسجد
الحرام بالتزامن مع موسم عمره استثنائي
واستعدادا لموسم حج هذا العام من الحرم
المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
ونعود الى المدينه المنوره الى مراسل
العربيه من هناك سلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا
بك كنت تحدثنا عن مختبر متنقل خاص بفحص
جوده وسلامه الاغذيه والمياه هدفنا عنهم
بشكل
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدين نشره
الرابعه قبل الخوض في تفاصيل هذا المختبر
المتنقل المتخصص في فحص الاطعمه والغذاء
والمياه كذلك والذي تم العمل عليه من قبل
امانه المدينه المنوره نتحدث انه المسجد
النبوي استقبل حتى 15 رمضان اكثر من 15
مليون و700 الف مصلي ومصليه ومائه 163
مليون منذ بدايه العام الحالي وتحديدا من
غره محرم وحتى اليوم ارقام كبيره يسجلها
المسجد النبوي
للمصلين والمصليات والمصلين نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره تم دخلت الى المسجد الاب
والاداء الصلوات وزيره الروضه الشريفه
كذلك نتحدث عن تنظيمات واعمال كبيره عملت
عليها رئاسه الحرمين لفتح المسجد النبوي
كامل للطاقه التشغيليه وهي 14
448 الف مصلي يستوعبه المسجد النبوي
والعدد تتضاعف كذلك في الساحات فيما يتعلق
بمختبر الغذاء المتنقل الذي او تعمل علي
امانه المدينه المنوره للكشف الاطعمه
والتاكد من سلامتها هنالك مختبر متنقل
بالقرب من المسجد النبوي نتحدث انه هذا
المختبر مجهز
السعوديه ليقومون بعمليات السحب العينات
من المياه والاطعمه حتى اليوم تمسح اكثر
من 50 او 65 عينه نتحدث انه يتم مسح اخذ
العينات من الارضيات والمشروبات وكذلك من
ايدي العاملين للتاكد من سلامتها من
البكتيريا او حتى الفيروسات المتعلقه
بالاطعمه ويتم مراقب او تم الدخول على
اكثر من 25 منشاه خاصه بالماكولات في
المسجد النبوي تحديدا في المنطقه المركزيه
للتاكد من سلامه المنشاه والعاملين داخل
هذه المنشاه مثل هذه الرقبات او الجولات
الرقابيه هي تعزز من صحه سلامه الزائرين
التي تعمل عليها امانه المدينه المنوره
للتاكد من سلامه المشاه التجاريه في هذا
الموسم الذي يشهد اقبال كبير وكما ذكرنا
قبل قليل اكثر من 15 مليون و700 الف مصلي
ومصليه اتوا الى المسجد النبوي لاداء
الصلوات وزياده الروضه الشريفه نتحدث
المتوقع خلال الايام القادمه ان تزداد هذه
الاعداد وتكبر هذه الاعداد بشكل كبير
وتزيد بشكل كبير جدا خلال العشره الاواخر
القادمه شكرا لك سلطان السلمي من المدينه
المنوره
هذا هو يوزعه في المسجد الحرام اكثر من 30
الف حافظه لماء زمزم في ساحاته ومرافقه
الخارجيه خلال شهر رمضان وتعمل رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين على توزيع ما يزيد عن 300 حقيبه
متنقله لتوزيع عبوات زمزم وثمانين عربه
ذكيه كما يقوم منسوب مختبر زمزم بجولات
يوميا لفحص مواقع توزيع ماء زمزم بمجموع
عينات يزيد عن 30 عينه يوميا وذلك عبر
منظومه عمل تستمر على مدار اليوم
اسبرت الحملات الميدانيه لمتابعه وضبط
مخالفي انظمه الاقامه والعمل وامن الحدود
في السعوديه عن ضبط حوالي 17 الف مخالف
للنظام الاقامه وامن الحدود والعمل في
كافه مناطق البلاد وبلغ اجمالي ومن تم
ضبطهم خلال محاولتهم عبور الحدود الى داخل
المملكه
1600 شخص في مكان عدده المضغوطين خلال
محاولتهم العبور الى خارج حدود السعوديه
بطريقه غير النظاميه 88 شخصا وكان
مواطنوها جنسيتين اليمنيه والاثيوبيه
الاكثر من المخالفين لانظمه الاقامه
والعمل في السعوديه ب 96% من المخالفين
اربعه مدن سعوديه تدخل لقائمه اذكى مدن
العالم لعام 2023
اهلا بكم من جديد اطلقت شركه التصنيف
الاعلاميه بيانات المشاهده التلفزيونيه
خلال شهر رمضان في السعوديه
والتي جمعت خلال الايام الخمسه الاولى من
الشهر الهجري الجاري بدقه لرسب نسب مشاهده
الجمهور البرامج والمسلسلات الرمضانيه ما
يسموه في مساعدات المعلنين من التخطيط
لحملاتهم الاعلانيه وفقا للشرائح
المستهدفه والبرامج الاعلى مشاهده لتطوير
قطاع الاعلان على اسس المتينه وقيم تعزز
الشفافيه
انا في استديوهاتنا من الرياض المهندس
بندر المشهدي رئيس التنفيذي لشركه تصنيف
الاعلاميه ام ار سي حياك الله الله
كل سنه وانت طيب وانت بخير وصحه وسلامه
شكرا
نبدا بالنتائج ولا نبدا
بالمعايير اللي اعتمدت عليها في القياس
يعني وانتم استخدمتم القياس الذهبي اقصد
فيه
معايير على اساس نوضح كيف احنا الحمد لله
بهذه الجزئيه اصبحنا على مستوى مقاييس
الدوليه والعالميه وسننتكلم لغه الارقام
اللي هي اللغه العالميه حلو قصه هذا
المشروع بدات من تقريبا عشرين سنه وهو
قياس نسب المشاهدين بطرق علميه وبارقام
دقيقه جدا بناء على مقاييس دوليه وعالميه
وضعت من قبل جهات مختلفه
تساهم في مساعده الشركات انها تصل
للشريحه المستهدفه عن طريق الاعلان والاهم
من ذلك
انك تستثمر في المحتوى
يتطلب الجماهير
وبحمد الله بتوفيق
الشركه اطلقت هذه البيانات من السنه
الماضيه من اكتوبر
وكنا نعرف شهر رمضان هو من احد اهم
المواسم التلفزيونيه وكانت ارقامنا ولله
الحمد مستخدما من جهات كثير سواء كانت
قنوات فضائيه او جهات تمثل معلنين او
معلنين
ونقدر نقول ان احنا نجحنا في هذا الموضوع
والان متجهين بشكل قوي جدا اننا نصل الى
المقياس الذهبي وهو المقياس الوحيد الذي
تعتمده جميع الشرك مقياس الذهبي يا طويل
العمر بناء على القياسات العالميه يجب ان
نصل الى مؤشرات اداء معينه مثلا دقه تكون
75% احنا الان 73% ايش معنى دقه ايش دقه
تجاوب الاجهزه والجماهير مع المشاهده انتم
وصلتوا ال75 المفروض 500 احنا نعم وايضا
عدد المنازل اللي
بنشغل التلفزيون بتشغل الجهاز الخاص
بمتابعه التلفزيون المفروض انه يكون 85%
احنا الان
تخطينا هذا الرقم احنا موجودين في 24
مدينه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه احنا
بنمثل
الشرائح السعوديه والمقيمين سواء العرب او
غير العرب في المملكه العربيه
بداتوا في الخمسه الايام الاولى من رمضان
الخمسه الاولى الايام الاولى من رمضان
اصدرنا تقرير يحدد المشاهدات اللي لاحظنا
انه تعرف اول خمسه ايام من رمضان مهمه جدا
للمعلنين ومهمه جدا
للقنات كلها
بالضبط في الشاشه متابعته واي نوع من
الشرائح تتابعوا في السابق كان في
استبيانات الان ارقام دقيقه لك
الباقراون تبين لك الاب او الام او
الابناء الاعمار الى اخ بس يحب وضح نقطتين
الاولى انه هذه
المرحله مركز على التلفزيون في المنزل
وليست على الاجهزه الذكيه والان المراحل
الثانيه حنتعامل مع الاجهزه الذكيه او ما
يسمى
النقطه الثانيه انه احنا الحمد لله
استلمنا الرخصه من هيئه الاعلام مرسموع
وهي رخصه وحده فقط انتم شركه نعم
او ميديا شركه تصنيف الاعلاميه وليش لازم
يكون رخصه وحده حتى انه يكون في مصدر
موثوق من شركه او من جهه قطاع خاص تعطي
هذه الارقام هذه اول مره استاذ خالد ولله
الحمد ارقام بيانات عن المشاهدات
للسعوديين والمقيمين في السعوديه تطلع من
داخل المملكه العربيه دقيقه نعم كيف وصلت
للجمهور بشكل راندوم كان عن طريق تواصل
بالتليفون تاكد من البيانات ونتطابق
الشريحه المطلوبه وبعدها يتم زياره المنزل
اول شيء لا انه نستوعب انت العائله كم عدد
وين ساكنين الجنسيه الباقران
واذا راينا انك تتناسب مع هذه الشريحه تتم
زياره المنزل يتم تركيب الجهاز وهو موصول
للتلفزيون فقط عن طريق سلك اوديو وما يسمع
الا للتلفزيون وبعدها يبين ما يتم مشاهدته
على هذا التلفاز
واذا طابقت المواصفات تصبح من ضمن هذه
الشريحه على سبيل المثال الموضوع متابعين
في المرسوم ملكي الخاص بحفظ البيانات
لدرجه اني انا ما اعرف مين هذه المنازل
ولا اعرف مين ارباب هذه المنازل فريق خاص
يتعامل مع ارباب هذه المنازل بسريه تامه
في نفس الوقت هذه احد الشروط الرئيسيه
اللي وضعت لنا من هيئه اعلان مري مسموع
وايضا من قبل المقاييس والستاندرز اللي
موجوده كم عدد المنازل 2300 2300 منزلتوها
في 24 مدينه نعم
كمقارنه نسبه السكر او عدد السكان في
المملكه صحيح بحدود 34 مليون لكن الشريحه
المستهدفه تجاريا هي 22 مليون نسمه في
بريطانيا عدد الشريحه المستهدفه 60 مليون
عندهم 5000 منزل فالرقم اللي احنا
مستخدمينه هو رقم عالمي والهدف الرئيسي من
هذا البرنامج واحد انه فعلا انا معلن يصل
الى الشريحه لكن اهم من ذلك السماح
للمستثمرين داخل وخارج المملكه انهم
ينظروا الى هذه البيانات حتى يستوعبوا فين
يقدروا تنشروها يعني
عن طريق سوفت وير نضع كل البيانات داخل
السيستم معين
والمشتركين معانا سواء كانت جهات حكوميه
قنوات تلفزيونيه
يصير عندهم يعني شرط انه تشترك هذه الجهات
عندكم على اساس تحصل على هذه البيانات وفي
نفس الوقت احنا عن طريق السوشيال ميديا في
الانستجرام وقنوات الخاصه فينا الام ار سي
ساودي برضو بنطلع ما يسمى بالوايت بيبر او
بيانات عامه بشكل عامه تعطيك احصاءات مثلا
انه في اول عشره ايام من رمضان وصل تقريبا
19 مليون مشاهد كابرج
ايضا متوسط مشاهده الرجال خمس ساعات
وعشرين دقيقه بينما السيدات خمس ساعات
واربعين دقيقه لقينا ايضا انه في رمضان
الامهات يقضون وقت اطول مع اطفالهم على
برامج خاصه بالاطفال فكل هذه البيانات
تبدا تعطيك انطباع ويعني واضح وارقامنا
الحمد لله تعطيك دقيقه بدقيقه وليست
استبيانات ربع ساعه الى نصف ساعه يمكن
السؤال الاهم هنا يبدو بعد ما اخذته انتم
نتائج والارقام اكيد في تباين كبير بين
ارقام ونسب المشاهده في فترات سابقه
واليوم
يمكن اعتمادكم كذلك على رمضان لانه رمضان
هو كعكه ايضا بالنسبه للكثير من القنوات
واقبال كبير عليها من المستثمرين او من
المعلنين سواء كان محلينا وغيرها لكن هل
مازال التلفزيون مغري الى اليوم مغري
اعلاميا للمزال يمثل
ماده تست
الارقام الحقيقيه
للعملاء عندنا حتى يقدر يتخذوا قرارات
صحيحه وليست بناء على ارقام ضعيفه يعطيكم
العافيه جزيلا لكم موفقين دائما شكرا لك
شكرا ديسبندر مشهوديه الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه تصنيف الاعلاميه
اقل من عامين متبقي على انتهاء اعمال بناء
مشروع حدائق الملك عبد الله العالميه التي
ستشكل نقله نوعيه في علوم النباتات
وتاريخها كما تعد ايضا
معلما مهما للعاصمه الرياض مراسل العربيه
يكشف في هذا التقليد تفاصيل المشروع
المنتظر واقسامه
تسارع في اعمال بناء مشروع حدائق الملك
عبدالله العالميه غرب الرياض نسبه الانجاز
للمشروع الضخم تجاوزت الاربعين في المئه
منذ عام 2019 عندما عملت امانه الرياض على
مواءمه المشروع مع اهداف رؤيه 2030
انجاز جميل جدا
من ناحيه اول شيء من ناحيه هندسيه بخبره
الهندسيه هذا ما يسمى بالكراشباث انها
تبدا في 2019 وتنتهي في انجاز من قطع
النظير ب 40% في خلال فتره وجيزه وانت
تستهدف ايضا 2024 لانهاء المشروع وهو
مشروع نادر وفريد من نوعه تصميم رائع جدا
متحف نباتي يعني عالمي على مستوى العالم
ويعكس صوره ايجابيه عن المملكه وهو احد
ايضا احد
جوانب السياحه للمملكه
فسيكون المشروع ايضا ليس فقط
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن ايضا
للعالم سيضيف قيمه مضافه للسياحه السعوديه
سيضيف قيمه مضاعفه مضافه للمواطن السعودي
لمعرفه انواع النباتات انواع الاشجار هذه
صور تخيليه للشكل الذي سيكون عليه المشروع
بعد الافتتاح لا يمكن تجاوز التصميم
الفريد لحدائق الملك عبد الله العالميه
والذي حصد عده جوائز عالميه نظيره تصاميمه
الابداعيه للحدائق التي تضم مئه وستين الف
شجره تمثل الفا واربعمائه نوع من النباتات
المحليه والمستورده
بالاضافه الى ان الحدائق العالميه ستشكل
بمساحتها الممتده على اكثر من مليونين متر
مربع مركزا مهما للاحداث الترفيهيه
والوطنيه الكبرى فانه يعد مختبرا واسعا
للباحثين العلميين في التغيرات المناخيه
بالعالم عبر سبع حدائق نباتيه تمثل الحقب
الزمنيه القديمه وسبع حدائق اخرى تقدم
نماذج من الترفيه المرتبط بالتعلم مع
حديقه الوادي التي تحوي عناصر الثروه
البيئيه للسعوديه باذن الله بنهايه العام
القادم 2024 بدايه 25 باذن الله سيكون
انتهاء المشروع والبدء تشغيل باذن الله
ستكون الحدائق العالميه الواقعه بالقرب من
مشروع الجديه معلما جديدا للعاصمه الرياض
ومعززا مهما للحركه الاقتصاديه بالبلاد
باصوله الاستثماريه حيث يتوقع ان تقترب
التكلفه الاجماليه للمشروع من ملياري ريال
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
الحرم المكي شريف في طرطغطيتنا مع مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم اهلا اسامه
ماذا لديك اليوم
اهلا وسهلا خالي تحيه طيبه عليك ولجميع
مشاهدي العربيه نقول لكم اليوم الصوت
والصوره من هنا من نطاف الدور الاول
وبالتحديد من امان الصبابات وصنابير
المسجد الحرام التي تقدم الان اتحدث اليوم
خالد عن اكثر من 30 الف حافظه توزع في
المسجد الحرام لسقيا زمزم ايضا هناك عدد
من الروبوتات تنزل الى صحن المطاف وتوزع
المياه وعلب المياه البلاستيكيه لسقي زمزم
هناك ما يزيد عن 30 الف حافظه لماء زمزم
موزعه في انحاء المسجد الحرام وساحاته
ومرافقه الخارجيه يتم تعبئتها خمس مرات
يوميا وتوفير ايضا ما يزيد عن 300 حقيبه
متنقله لتوزيع عبوات زمزم ايضا هناك اكثر
من 80 عربه ذكيه بسعه 80 لتر توزع المياه
في انحاء المسجد الحرام طبعا تقوم الرئاسه
من خلال وكاله الخدمات وشؤون الميدانيه
باداره خدمات سقيا زمزم باكثر من 130 عامل
كما يقوم ايضا المنسوبون المختبر بجولات
يوميه لفحص مواقع توزيع ماء زمزم بمجموع
عينات يزيد تقريبا عن ثلاثين عينه يوميا
عبر منظومه عمل تستمر على مدار اربع
وعشرين ساعه طبعا خالد ونحن نتحدث عن
سوقيا زمزم بالتاكيد ان اعداد الزوار
المعتمرين التي وصلت الى اليوم الى قرابه
سته عشر مليون زائر ومعتمر كما نشاهد في
الصوره هذه الاعداد تاكيد تحتاج الى تكثيف
الكثير من عدد النترات الموزعه اليوم في
المسجد الحرام ومن مصدر مسؤول ايضا في
اداره سقيا زمزم برئاسه شؤون الحرمين هناك
تكثيف ايضا لهذه العمليات خلال العشر
الاواخر بالتزامن مع الخطه التشغيليه
الثالثه وهي الخطه التشغيليه للعشر
الاواخر طبعا خرجنا قبل قليل من منطقه
تعبئه هذه الحافظات بنقطه توسعه الملك فهد
هناك اكثر من منطقه يتم فيها تعبئه هذه
الحافظات ثم النقلها الى ساحات ومداخل
المسجد الحرام طبعا تتم هذه العمليه في
خلال اقل من 30 دقيقه يتم تتم تعبئه
المسجد الحرام بالكامل سواء عبر الحافظات
او عبر الصنابير او حتى عبر العلب
البلاستيكيه التي توزع في صحن المطاف شكرا
لك اسامه القاسم مراسم العربيه من الحرم
المكي الشركه يعطيك العافيه استاذ
استقبلت المحاكم السعوديه اكثر من 32 الف
طلبا لفكراني عقارات بزياده
39% عن نفس الفتره من العام الماضي وذلك
حسب ما نشرت نشرت صحيفه الاقتصاديه
السعودي
استحدثت الرياض وفقطت صحيفه على الطلبات
والدعاء باكثر من 22 الف طلبا ما يشكل 71%
من الدعاوى
مناطق المدينه المنوره باكثر من الالف طلب
ثم القسيم والحدود الشماليه بحوالي 1500
لكلا المنطقه
اعلنا مؤشر ام اي دي للمدن الذكيه في
العالم عن دخول اربع مدن سعوديه الى قائمه
اذكى مدن العالم لعام 2022 هي رياض جده
مكه والمدينه المنوره وحلت العاصمه
السعوديه في المركز الثالث عربيا
والثلاثين عالميا وفق مؤشر المدن الذكيه
الصادره عن المعهد الدوري للتنميه
الاداريه والذي ارجع ذلك الى تحسن جوده
الحياه في عده مجالات واستخدام التقنيه في
مواجهه التحديات
اختتم رئيس هيئه الترفيه السعوديه التركيه
للشيخ النسخه الثانيه من مسابقه القران
الكريم ورفع الاذان برنامج عطر الكلام
وفاز عشرون متسابقا بجوائز تصل قيمتها الى
اكثر من 12 مليون ريال وجاء السعودي محمد
الشريف في المركز الاول في فئه الاذان
بمبلغ مليونيريال وفز الايراني يونس شاهمر
شاهم راضي في فئه التلاوه بمبلغ ثلاثه
ملايين ريال وحصدت المسابقه ست شهادات من
موسوعه جينيس للارقام القياسيه
صاحب المركز الرابع في فئه الاذان ابراهيم
اسد
انضمت نائبه رئيس الاتحاد السعودي
للبلياردو سنوكر نجلاء العليان الى عضويه
الاتحادات الرياضيه الدوليه لتكون بذلك
اول السعوديه عضوه في الاتحاد وممثله عن
القاره الاسيويه في لجنه المراه بالاتحاد
الدولي اي بي اس اف
شغلت مناصب عده في القطاع الرياضي كان
مستهلها نائبه مديره الشؤون الرياضيه في
جامعه الاميره نوره في السعوديه عام 2019
توقع مركز الارصاد في السعوديه هطول امطار
رعديه مصحوبه برياحا نشطه مثيره للاتربه
والغبار واشار المركز الى ان الامطار
ستشمل معظم مناطق البلاد وتبدا حسب
التوقعات من يوم الاحد القادم وحتى يوم
الخميس
احتفل الفنان محمد رمضان عبر حسابه في
انستجرام بتخطي هاشتاق جعفر العمده مليار
مشاهده على التيك توك المسلسل يشارك في
بطولته بجانب محمد رمضان مجموعه كبيره من
النجوم ويدور في اطار اجتماعي شعبي المزيد
دائما في كواليس مع سؤال وايهم القسم
[موسيقى]
19 سنه بقولها
وما فيش حاجه بتهون
وانا عملت ايه غلط في حياتي
بالاحرمني من الاثنين
مرحبا ارقام كبيره من ناحيه المشاهدات
يحققها جعفر العمده لاسباب عديده ابرزها
جماهيريه محمد رمضان ومحمد سامي واشتياق
الجمهور لهما معا بالاضافه لوقت العرض
المناسب جدا لكن ورغم هذه الارقام هناك
اتهامات مستمره بالمبالغه والسؤال كيف
ولماذا انا شايف انه السنه دي محمد رمضان
ومحمد سامي المخرج مركزين جدا ان هم
يعملوا نجاح شعبي وشعبوي كبير جدا اكتر من
ان هم حتى
دورنا قمنا بزياره منطقه السيده زينب
وسؤال اهاليها عن رايهم بالعمل وبالمنطقه
بحسب رؤيه محمد سامي او اعمل لي السيده
زينب خليها كبير واحد انما السيده زينب دي
منطقه الكبش والسيده زينب والمدبح وزينب
والدوران والسيده دي كلها ما لهاش كبير كل
واحد له واحد في كبير مش كبير بقى واحد
محترم في منطقته هو اللي بيحل المشاكل
انما واحد فرداني للسيده زينب عمر السيده
زينب ابدا ولا التصوير ده خالص في السيده
زينب
يعني صلاح السعدني ربنا يدي له الصحه كان
زمان عمل مسلسل برده هنا اهو جابوا
التصوير كله هنا في السيده كان بيصور في
جميع السيده والتصوير وكله جاب جامع
السيده انما ده ما جابش اي حاجه في السيده
خالص دي معموله غير السيده زينب خالص
المنطقه دي انا من السيده زينب بقى لي 25
سنه هنا عمري كله ما شفتش العموديه دي
خالص ولا العرف اللي هو بيتكلم عليه كل
واحد في حاله دلوقتي
انما زمن كان فيه الاعداد وصلح وبتاع
ويجيبوا الناس ويقعدوا معاهم وكده انما
دلوقتي ما فيش زفوني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الختام بابرس العناوي
وابدو ان عراقي برئاسه مستشار الامن
القومي يصل الى السليمانيه لبحث حادثه
الهجوم على المطر
سلطات شبه جزيره القرم تعلن اسقاط صاروخ
اوكراني وتؤكد عدم تسجيل اي اضرار نتيجه
الحادثه
امين عام منظمه التعاون الاسلامي يحذر من
اي محاوله لتغيير وضع المقدسات في القدس
الجريده الرسميه السعوديه تنشر تعديلات
نظام حمايه البيانات الشخصيه
الوصول والاتلاف ضمن ابرزها
والابصاد السعوديه تتوقع استمراره طول
الامطار على مختلف المناطق حتى الخميس
القادم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات